so i'm curious as as content creators
and youtubers
um who have not given their feedback
influencers as influencers
who have not actually given their
feedback to youtube is there
anything you would like to say to
youtube to improve the platform
is there any actual feedback you would
like to give to youtube
apart from and hopefully they'll
actually hear us
uh that's a good question i don't know
yeah because
like for me like i don't know
there's another system that's just been
recently implemented and it's the
checking system
uh yeah like i i uploaded a video
recently
and yeah so so for those of you who
don't know
um when when you upload a video uh
youtube used to do like some pre-checks
to make sure it was like content
friendly and content
contents monetizable now those checks
for for absolutely no reason
just take an hour plus yes
yeah i feel i don't know if it's because
it's like this new system is in beta or
whatever but
but i heard nothing about this they
weren't transparent about that at all
yeah yeah yeah
i remember like the first time it
happened on one of my videos i was like
oh no am i in trouble yeah what's going
on why are they like
diagnosing yeah why are they like
[ __ ] like enhance enhance this video
to be like we gotta find at least one
frame where we could [ __ ]
sick this guy i don't know i don't know
who the [ __ ] is in charge of pr but like
why does it always feel that when they
like tell us something
finally they tell us something it's like
just the dumbest [ __ ]
like we didn't need to know that the
dislikes are being removed probably yeah
how about you just reply to my emails
when i'm like having a problem like yeah
i think that's the one thing that has
consistently been an issue that i think
everyone talks about which is like
communication and the fact that when you
have an issue
that could be very simple just becomes
ten times more difficult because
you're just like [ __ ] you i'm not gonna
talk to you yeah and then it's like well
you know it's not like you're you're not
making a decent money for youtube you
know yeah
that's your living it feels like well
you know well that's the thing right
like and that's part that's the part
where i can't exactly be like
wow youtube i can't believe you ignore
us like that because i mean [ __ ] like
how many channels are there now that
have over a million subs right
yeah already that's like thousands and
thousands and there's just there's
probably all of those youtubers probably
have at least
one period in their life where they're
like i need you to reply to me so yeah
i i feel like how how often do you need
to email youtube for help
like once a year at most yeah like maybe
once or twice so then like
at that level right let's say if there
is like some kind of mythical
barrier it's like a million subs you get
to have someone that doesn't seem too
unreasonable to me
but also i feel like it's something that
you should just doesn't want to do
either i don't want to [ __ ] with that
and and again like you know that would
be fine if
it was only those like million plus subs
who even have
access to the youtube email right yeah
literally you know you could have a
channel with [ __ ] 10 subs be like um
youtube why did you delete my video
please help right yeah
so it's like because most of the you
know if you if you
are a youtuber right you'll probably
follow an account called team youtube on
twitter
yeah which is like youtube customer
support but not on their own [ __ ]
platform yeah
you know you might treat them something
that gets like tons of attention tons of
stuff and then
they won't reply to it but they'll be
replying to someone who's like like a
bunch of other people who are like hey i
got locked out of my account they're
like oh well
here's how you can do it like [ __ ] that
in order to get youtube's attention you
literally have to ratio them no you do
i mean you have to you have to spam them
it's unfortunate yeah you do it's like
you just got ratio youtube's like [ __ ]
you got me all right we'll help you out
it's like how well can you ratio that's
how quickly
we will reply to your email but also you
know like i've i've heard people who
have gotten
immense amount of help just because they
you know went to like one youtube event
met a youtube employee and then they'll
pull strings for you
yeah right and and that feels like it's
like being in like [ __ ] prison it's
like well your mate knows the prison
guard so you're not going to get shanked
yeah yeah well how is that fair like i'm
stuck in this system and i have to work
with you yeah i can't [ __ ] do it
maybe i don't want to go to your [ __ ]
workshop youtube have you thought about
that maybe i just want some help
because my video got wrong too because
the only time i ever got help from
youtube was um
because i got very lucky and um
i had a really good partner manager who
was super super like
i think i think at the time they were
new to youtube and they were super down
like
really be in depth and talk with me and
be like hey what do you need what do you
need help with
and and they were very nice and helped
me out a lot you know and
i was just sitting there the whole time
i was getting all this help i was like
oh my god like i sent how many [ __ ]
emails did so many other things reach up
to so many people
all it took was just one youtube
employee who was nice to me who
recommended me to like the engineering
team or whatever yeah yeah and all my
problems got fixed
and it's like this is so dumb that this
is what it takes
i have to be like i should have a man on
the inside to help me out
you need a double agent it's like you
know and and
they don't work there anymore so i don't
even have the health anymore so now i'm
[ __ ] by the issues
i just gotta like cry on twitter and
it's i hate doing that i don't want your
child
right